[Música]
donald trump se convirtió en el primer
presidente en la historia de eeuu en ser
sometido a dos juicios políticos fue
acusado de incitación a la insurrección
tras la toma al capitolio trump
respondió sin mencionar el impeachment y
cambiando de postura condenando la
violencia en la sede legislativa los
expertos de la organización mundial de
la salud ya se encuentran en jan para
estudiar el origen de el coronavirus sin
embargo le fue negada la entrada al país
a dos miembros del equipo que aún se
encuentran en singapur en semana
reciente es el director general de la
uem se señaló que hubo trabas para que
la misión llegará a sólo chino
y abrieron los centros de votación en
uganda bajo una fuerte presencia militar
y en medio de un completo apagón de las
comunicaciones con el acceso a internet
restringido más de 17 millones de
ugandeses se eligen una vez más entre el
presidente yoweri museveni que busca su
sexta reelección o una decena de
candidatos de la oposición
hola como estan buenos dias en américa
latina' ya todos ustedes que nos siguen
por la señal de france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria sean bienvenidos
empezamos en eeuu la cámara de
representantes- obtuvo la mayoría
necesaria para aprobar un segundo juicio
político contra el donald trump acusado
de haber incitado a la insurrección
después del asalto al capitolio por
parte de sus seguidores el 6 de enero
todo queda ahora en manos del senado
donde el proceso comenzaría la semana
entrante
trump respondió en un vídeo cambiando de
tono sin hacer mención del impeachment y
condenándola violencia en el capitolio
es por ello que enlazamos con jorge
jáuregui él es abogado
constitucionalista muchas gracias por
esta comunicación abogado el líder
republicano mitch mcconnell ha dicho que
un juicio político no concluiría antes
de la llegada de joe biden al poder por
lo que removerá a donald trump del cargo
ya no parece una opción viable cuál será
entonces el objetivo principal de este
juicio abogado
buenos días es un gran placer estar a
sus órdenes no encantado el limpieza o
juicio político que en realidad se da en
el senado
tiene dos posibilidades una opción es la
de remover en el cargo a una autoridad a
un oficial público que es lo que incluye
el presidente le respondió en el caso
del sistema constitucional
estadounidense o también e inhabilitarlo
eso que se respeten las constituciones
latinoamericanas la figura de la
inhabilitación para el ejercicio de
cargo público futuro y entonces podría
ser ambas posibilidades ahora lo que sí
es cierto es este hecho el digamos esto
este asalto el capitolio es percibido
casi como un autogolpe la figura aquí
lamentablemente en democracia es un poco
más débil es el caso de las
latinoamericanas sea como el nombre del
autogolpe decir cuando un jefe de estado
propicia un quiebre institucional para
permanecer en el poder o en todo caso
para desconocer el resultado electoral
que es propiamente el caso del señor
trans no le ha estado ha explicado una
estrategia la regla del conocimiento del
resultado electoral ha acusado de cosas
falsas y en este caso públicamente ha
estado alentando actos de violencia para
resistirse
al proceso constitucional o el resultado
electoral entonces hay también este
aspecto que es súper importante que este
punto de inflexión que ha dejado muy
golpeada a la democracia norteamericana
que hay que decirlo es una democracia
emblemática de la más antigua del mundo
y además siempre fue una un sistema
paradigmático toda buen funcionamiento
del sistema representación pero en los
últimas en las últimas décadas hemos
visto que ha habido bastantes
complicaciones y particularmente en este
caso momento el señor tram implica un
punto inflexión porque se ha roto esa
estabilidad y ese respeto al orden
constitucional que tradicionalmente ha
caracterizado 6000
es eso creo también en no dejar que esto
pase como un hecho regular tiene que
haber una sanción política para eso está
pensado estos imposiciones o juicios
políticos que no le hace a en esta
segunda cámara no hay un plazo así que
esto no creo que sea corto no creo que
sea pronto pero tiene que ver una
respuesta ahora el problema es bastante
más complejo es una sociedad escindida
en la que digamos empobrecido y por lo
tanto al igual como pasó en la segunda
guerra mundial esto da mucho miedo en el
caso de alemania sectores muy
empobrecidos logran generar el insumo
humano para el surgimiento de estos
estos regímenes infractores de la
constitución uno incluso se decantan en
totalitarismo esto parece que se ha dado
de eeuu y no solamente es enseñarse y
estar incitando como se le ha acusado
porque ya tiene una acusación a nivel de
la de abogado en representantes
y ahora ya a niveles del senado se va
realmente a llevar el orgullo político
no encendido abogado nos quedan unos 45
segundos disculpe que lo interrumpa que
quería preguntar sobre la presidencia de
trump pues deja un partido republicano
fracturado evidenciado por el voto de 10
republicanos de la cámara baja en su
contra puede el partido darse el lujo de
darse la espalda a donald trump ya su
movimiento político reiteró nos quedan
40 segundos es cumplir la pregunta
realmente complicada y hay que pensar
que también es la decisión que se da del
senado es política en este caso su
juicio político y que va a ser objeto
del señor tram es complicado porque
entran tiene algún respaldo electoral
interesante no y él
dado que no se siente totalmente
republicano no se siente tan pista o sea
en un movimiento como propio ciertamente
esto puede ha fracturado al partido
republicano como usted bien lo señala
hay 222 votos demócratas en la cámara
representantes para aprobar la la
acusación en 10 votos republicanos que
se sumaron entonces hay un partido
descendido pero hay que hacer una cosa
el persona pública no durante todos
estos últimos cuatro años ha ido
mintiendo sistemáticamente respecto a
varios temas ha sido bastante digamos
este flexible como tal yo creo que
finalmente es posible que giren ese
entorno es muy posible que giren en
torno a su forma de liderazgo que sin
duda no es democracia
pues muchas gracias
sigan los votos
muchas gracias lo interrumpo nuevamente
gracias por su análisis por su
comprensión al abogado
constitucionalista pero vámonos otros
temas porque este jueves un equipo de
expertos de la organización mundial de
la salud llegó a bojan para investigar
los orígenes del virus esto después de
haberse por la falta de
autorización de beijing el equipo pasará
alrededor de un mes en un hang
incluyendo dos semanas en cuarentena sin
embargo se negó la entrada a dos
miembros del equipo después de que ambos
dieran positivo en las pruebas de
anticuerpos contra el cob y 19
los expertos de la organización mundial
de la salud están finalmente en la cuna
de la epidemia buján ha pasado un poco
más de un año desde que china anunció la
primera muerte por cúbicas y nueve en
esa ciudad
el grupo internacional de expertos tiene
que hacer primero una cuarentena durante
este periodo los científicos chinos y
expertos médicos estarán en una extensa
comunicación con los expertos
internacionales a través de
videoconferencia
sobre si visitaran otras partes de china
creo que tendrán que antes completar su
primera parada su investigación en wuhan
antes de poder considerar su pregunta
sin embargo las autoridades chinas
impidieron la entrada de dos miembros
del equipo después de que dieron
positivo en las pruebas de anticuerpos
en singapur china asegura estar
aplicando las medidas preventivas de
manera estricta inicialmente prevista la
semana pasada la llegada de los expertos
fue cancelada en el último minuto debido
a que beijing no había transmitido todas
las utilizaciones necesarias pero los
residentes de buján acogieron con
satisfacción la visita es un poco tarde
para que vengan pero más vale tarde que
nunca será útil para ellos encontrar los
orígenes de la enfermedad lugar en donde
surgió por primera vez
la llegada de la misión de la oea se
coincide con la noticia sobre un nuevo
fallecimiento por el coronavirus en
china primera muerte que se produce en
ocho meses en el país los expertos dudan
que esta primera misión arroje
resultados concluyentes sobre los
orígenes del virus el continente
americano alcanzó la cifra récord de 25
millones de nuevos contagios por hobby
19 en la última semana de esta manera
américa suma casi 40 millones de casos y
un total de 925 mil muertes y según la
organización panamericana de la salud si
la población y los gobiernos se relajan
el 2021 podría ser peor que el año
pasado informe de adán días
américa es la región más afectada por el
coronavirus en el mundo con un total de
40 millones de casos y casi un millón de
muertes atraviesa el peor momento de la
pandemia según la organización
panamericana de la salud en que las
ubican un sólo en la última semana 2,5
millones de personas se contagiaron por
el cob y de 19 en nuestra región
la cifra de casos de semanal más elevada
desde que el virus ha alcanzado nuestras
costas por primera vez eeuu encabeza la
lista con 23 millones de contagios y más
de 380.000 fallecidos le sigue brasil
con 8 millones 256 mil casos y con 205
mil muertes por commit 19 es el segundo
con más fallecidos en el mundo después
del gigante sudamericano las naciones
con más contagios son colombia argentina
y méxico en colombia que tiene un millón
381 mil contagios el presidente iván
duque extendió la emergencia sanitaria
hasta el 28 de febrero mientras se
enfrenta una controversia por su lento
proceso de adquisición de vacunas
hoy quiero informarle al país que ese
decreto de aislamiento selectivo con
distanciamiento individual responsable
se extiende hasta el 28 de febrero de la
mano con la emergencia sanitaria y
méxico es el país con la mayor
mortalidad del mundo 135 mil personas de
las 1 millón 556.000 positivas han
fallecido es decir el 87 por ciento
otros países como cuba con 500 contagios
diarios o perú con una huelga de médicos
indefinida vive también contextos
extremos según la organización
panamericana de la salud prácticamente
todas las naciones de las américas han
visto una aceleración y están
desbordadas por el cob y 19
alemania registró un nuevo máximo con
1200 44 muertos en 24 horas después del
anterior récord de 1188 el viernes la
cifra de contagios acumulados acerca a
los 2 millones y el de víctimas mortales
a 43 mil 881 alemania se encuentra en un
segundo confinamiento con limitaciones
para desplazarse a más de 15 kilómetros
del lugar de residencia y según el
ministro de finanzas- olaf scholz el
confinamiento se podría mantener durante
mucho tiempo
nos vamos ahora el líbano porque el país
decreto del estado de emergencia tras un
grave incremento de los casos diarios y
una presión cada vez más fuerte sobre
los servicios sanitarios el
endurecimiento de las medidas
restrictivas durarán al menos hasta el
25 de enero desde beirut nuestra
corresponsal del bonete nos detalla más
beirut se ha levantado hoy así de vacía
y es que no es para menos el líbano es
el país con más casos de contagio por
coronavirus per cápita con una media a 4
mil 500 contagios diarios entre una
población que no llega a 5 millones esto
ha llevado a un colapso total de los
hospitales en beirut por ejemplo la
ocupación de camas hospitalarias llega
al 97 por ciento mientras que en otras
ciudades ha llegado al cien por cien
esto ha llevado a que las autoridades
libanesas tomen medidas draconianas con
un confinamiento total y toques de queda
de 24 horas hasta el próximo 25 de enero
que podría prorrogarse los negocios e
instituciones públicas y privadas
permanecerán cerradas y los
supermercados y fruterías sólo tendrán
servicio delivery el aeropuerto de
beirut permanecerá abierto pero todos
los viajeros que lleguen tendrán que
guardar una cuarentena de entre 3 días y
una semana en un hotel
las autoridades libanesas no han sabido
gestionar la pandemia y ahora los
libaneses están pagando los excesos de
las fiestas navideñas
uganda vive este jueves una jornada de
elecciones presidenciales y legislativas
en las que el mandatario yoweri museveni
en el poder desde 1986 busca seguir al
frente del gobierno son unos 18 millones
de votantes que eligen entre 11
candidatos este día llega después de un
apagón de redes sociales ha ordenado por
el ejecutivo un equipo de france 24 nos
reporta más sobre la jornada electoral
ugandesa
normalmente esta camarera aprovecha sus
descansos para revisar noticias en las
redes sociales pero en la antesala de
las elecciones las autoridades ugandesas
apagaron estas plataformas a las 130 no
me podía meter en nada
el apagón llega después de que facebook
cerrará unas cuentas cercanas al
gobierno el lunes el gigante tecnológico
afirma que descubrió una red de perfiles
falsos vinculados al ministerio de
información una situación que ha tenido
consecuencias económicas directas en
gente como este vendedor de servicios
telefónicos los perdí muchos negocios
porque tengo clientes que viven muy
lejos de aquí que envían mensajes a
través de las redes sociales que hablan
usando estas plataformas y yo les
respondo por ahí también así que ahora
mismo no nos podemos comunicar sin redes
en la vida diaria se hace difícil en
momentos de crisis
communication esta es la única manera en
medio del cob y 19 a través de la que la
gente puede comunicarse con los centros
electorales y las líneas de ayuda es
aquí en donde pueden pedir ayuda si algo
está ocurriendo
con la votación en marcha estar al tanto
de lo que sucede podría ahora ser más
difícil para la mayoría de los ugandeses
llegamos al final de esta emisión les
agradecemos mucho su compañía los
invitamos a que sigan con más noticias y
al momento de nuestra señal televisiva y
en nuestro sitio web y también a que se
cuiden y mucho del cob it is it
[Música]